abone ol
bu
Merhabalar ben Birol Güven
1964 yılında Kocaeli küçük bir sahil
Kasabası olan Darıca'da dünyaya geldim
hala oradayım platolarımız doğruyu
kurduk dizileri filmleri falan orada
çekiyoruz oyuncu arkadaşlarımızla Orayı
çok seviyor ekipte çok seviyor ve
yıllarda oyuncuları çok seviyor beni
zaten seviyorlar hepsi akrabam Ben zaten
dalıcam ünlüsü tüm Google'a darıcalı
ünlüler yazınca genelde ben çıkıyorum
zaten bir tek ben çıkıyorum Birkaç yıl
önce bir açılışa katılmıştım Ben
Darıca'da dışın ileri gelenlerinden biri
mikrofonu aldı elleme dedi ki bizim iki
şeyimiz çok ünlüdür dedi Darıca'daki şey
çok ünlüdür çok meşhurdur ikisiyle de
gurur duyuyoruz ikisiyle de iftar
ediyoruz dedi birisi Birol güvendiğini
hayvanat bahçesi dedi
beni daha öncesinde Bizimkiler 1923
yılında gelmiş kaplanlardan önce ben bu
Çocuğum çok küçük yaştan itibaren
dükkanda çalışmaya başladım babamın
yanında ne kadar küçük yaşta çalışmaya
başladım hatırlamıyorum ama 11 yaşımda
kamyonet kullanmaktan mahkemeye çıktık
Babamla birlikte
kayıtlarda var
19 yaşıma geldiğim zaman bana Aslında
ben ömrümün sonuna kadar babamın
Yanındaki Yanında çalışmayı düşünüyordum
ama o kadar uzun süre esnaflık yaptık ki
ben 19 yaşında Vazgeçtim ve üniversiteye
gittim Hacettepe Üniversitesi İngiliz
dilbilimi de okudum üniversitenin son
yılında biz iki arkadaşımızla birlikte
bir komedi grubu kurduk sahneye
çıkıyordu kampüsteki eventlerde
insanlar bize çok gülüyorlardı Çünkü bir
starımız Vardı bizim Mesut Öztürk ve
arkadaşımız gerçekten çok yetenekliydi
özellikle Özay Gönlüm taklidini çok iyi
yapıyordu Özay Gönlüm ve genç her yer
bilmeyebilir ama Türk halk müziğinin
efsanevi ismidir Mesut sahneye çıkardı
Böyle gıdı gıdı leh derdi salon
yıkılırdı sonra Barış Manço İlhan İrem
Zeki Alasya Metin Akpınar falan
taklitlerle Salonu yıkardı ve sonra Biz
çıkardık
böyle artçı Sarsıntı gibi bize de
gülerlerdi ama bize gülerken yani şey
gibi gülerler Siz çok havaya girmeyin
Biz Mesut'un hatırına gülüyoruz size
derlerdi ama biz bundan şikayetçi
değildik sonra bir gün bir arkadaş geldi
dedi ki siz dediğine ve animatör
olmuyorsunuz dedi dedik nedir
animatörlük dedi burada yaptıklarının
aynısını turistlerle yapacaksınız lüks
otellerde beş yıldızlı tatil köylerinde
falan turist kızlarla falan yapacaksınız
deyince Biz 3 arkadaş
ömrümüzün Ondan sonrasını animatör
olarak geçirmeye karar verdik bize
Antalya'ya da Bodrum'da şu anda tam ben
yapmadım çünkü İnsan bazı şeyleri
unutmak istiyor bir tatil köyünde iş
ayarladı lar Biz tatil köyüne gittik
sahneye çıkacağız otobüse bindik gittik
sıramın gelmesini bekliyoruz bir
yemekhane gibi bir yer 500 yılda 1000
bilmiyorum Alman turist yemeklerini
yemiş oturuyorlar bizi güldürün diyorlar
bir sahne yok Bir restoranda Yani ilk
saniye çıktığımız yer sahnede değildi
bizden önce bir Alman turist Almanları
güldürmeye Çalışıyordum ama onu da
gülüyorlardı yani Dedik ya insan hali
gurbette bir hemşiri seni güldürmeye
çalışır Niye gülüyorsunuz falan ona da
gülmediler Ne dedik ki şimdi birazdan
Mesut çıkar
ortalığı yıkar sonra biz çıkarız bize de
gülerler falan Mesut çıktığı almanlara
Özay Gönlüm taklidiyle girdi dedi ki
gıdı gıdı leh dedi bu almanlarda çıt yok
acaba dedi Yanlış mı Anlaşıldı ömür bir
kez daha yaptı gıdı gıdı L Çünkü normal
şartlarda salonun yıkılması gerekiyor
olmadı Barış Manço olmadı İlhan İrem
Demirel Ecevit Erbakan hiçbir şey
gülmediler Mesut kısa kesti Çıktı
sahneden
Mesut'a gülmeyen bize hiç gülmezdi
gülmediler bizim Hani derler ya bu sefer
güldürmedi Biz ilk seferinde de
güldüremedi cpe bizim sahne hayatımızı
Yaklaşık dört buçuk dakika sürdü sonra
biz bir durum değerlendirmesi yaptık
dedik ki bu animatörlük bize göre değil
vazgeçtik Mesut İngilizce öğretmeni oldu
Mehmet tur rehberi oldu ben bir süre
brene yapacağıma karar veremedim
sonra biraz özendim Biz o dönemde bizim
bölümlerde de modaydı tur rehberi olmak
Ben de tur rehberi olmaya karar verdim
kursa ve bu ettim böyle uzun altı aylık
bir kursa devam ettik ama ne kadar zor
bir kuş işte sanat tarihi arkeoloji
psikoloji antropoloji felsefe siyaset
aklınıza ne gelirse bir aylık da bir
Tura çıktık
dediler Dedik Anladık ki bu tur
rehberliği hiç göründüğü gibi değil çok
zor bir meslek çok okumak gerekiyor çok
bilgili olmak gerekiyor çünkü turist her
şeyi sorabilir kursta hocalarımız diyor
ki sakın acele etmeyin tura çıkmak için
buradan mezun olur olmaz Tura çıkmayın
böyle bir çıraklık dönemi geçirin onu
apranti diyorlar Bir o Yani bir sezon
bir tecrübeli rehberlerle birlikte süre
çıkıp Benimde hedefim bu zaten hiç
Acelem yok bir sezon bekleyebilirim
değişik arkadaşlarım var onlarla tura
çıkacağım Sonra kısa şehir içi turlar
İstanbul'da falan küçük gruplarda çıkıp
bir yıl sonra Turist rehberi olarak
çalışmaya başlayacağım eve gel bu
telefon çaldı bir arkadaşım oluyor dedi
ki Birol bir tur var çıkar mısın dedim
tur ne zaman tarih nedir dedi ki Grup şu
anda uçakta
Avustralya'da 38 kişi Singapur Singapur
üzerinden geliyorlar altında
havalimanında lar dedim çıkamam ben daha
rehber olalı Yarım saat oldu lan mümkün
değil yok dedi yaparsın zaten İstanbul
zaten Çanakkale Bergama Truva nefes hep
bildiğin yerler Sen zaten oralara Gittim
gittim falan konuştuk kapattım telefona
kabul etmedim ev arkadaşlarım var Nedim
ve Ercan bunlar aynı kursta beraberdik
ama birisi İtalyanca birisi bu
İspanyolca rehberler di 5-6 yıldır Kaçak
rehberlik yapıyorlardı çok tecrübeli
diller bana dediler ki Saçmalama Sen bu
işi çok rahat yaparsınız zaten Bir turda
rehber önemli değildir kim önemlidir
şoför bu girdi şoför otobüs şoförü o
kadar tecrübelidir ki o her şeyi bilir
seni alır götürür restoranları bile
müzeleri bilir Ören yerlerini bilir Sen
indirirsin grubu işte bildiğin kadar
anlatırsın bilmiyorsan fotoğraf molası
falan verirsin hem Avustralyalı 38 kişi
çok para kızacaksın Avustralya lı kızlar
da çok güzel olur falan derken ben sabah
6'da kendimi Atatürk Havalimanı'nda
buldum Elimde bir dosya Neyse benim Grup
çıktı Ben genci 78 yaşındaydı
ortalamamız 86 ydı bazıları böyle 90
falandı
yardımla yürüyebiliyor lardı Neyse ben
dedim tecrübe olsun
aldım grubu otobüse gittim otobüsü
buldum Yılmaz abi plaka doğru bindirdik
arabaya turistleri Valizleri
yerleştirdik Yılmaz abi dedim Otele
gidelim Yılmaz abi dedi ki Otel nerede
Evet şimdi Otel nerede diye sormaz bir
şeyler Hangi otel diye sorabilir çok yol
bütün otelleri biliyordur hangi özel
Hayır Otel nerede dedi abi dedim Sen
bilmiyor musun Hani bu acının sürekli
kaldığı otel oraya gideceğiz yok dedi
Bilmem Bu Benim İlk durum dedi
Yılmaz abi de kamyonculuk Tan vazgeçmiş
kariyer değişikliği yapmış O da ilk
turuna çıkmış Neyse ben dosyadan otelin
adresini buldum Yılmaz abi zor olsa da
Laleli buldu lalama Oteli bulamadık da
orada bir büfe büfe büfede indik Ben
sigara alma bahanesiyle
gittim abi dedim şu teli Bana
çaktırmadan tarif eder misin dedim ve o
anda anladım ki Türk insanı elini kolunu
sallamadan tarih yapamıyor Adam hemen
dışarı çıktı dedi buradan gideceğim sağ
döneceğim sola Ben arkamı bir döndüm
38 Avustralya'da cama yapışmış fotoğraf
çekiyor Bir dakika bir gol bir şoför de
rehberde dağ Oteli bulamıyor zaten bu
turda bir o kadar çok böyle sigara aldık
O kadar çok Bu adres sorduk yani Yılmaz
abinin önünde bir sigara daha oluştu
Yılmaz abi şey dedi Keşke daha önce
gitseydim turizme dedi hani sigara ya da
para vermiyor
Arkadaşlar ben oturda bizim başımıza da
Pardon o 38 Avustralya lının başına
gelmeyen kalmadı hiç bir yeri bulamadık
otelleri bulamadık Ören yerlerini
bulamadık müzeleri bulamadık Mola
yerlerini bulamadık ya milleti bulamadık
adamlar felsefeyi bulmuş Biz felsefenin
bulunduğu yeri bulamadık görmeden
gittiler Bir de ben nasıl hiçbir şeyi
Bilmiyorum her şeyi yanlış anlatıyorum
Helenistik diyorum Roma çıkıyor Roma
diyorum Selçuklu çıkıyor Selçuklu
diyorum işte Osmanlı çıkıyor var fakat
biz e-kurs O bir rehber asla bilmiyorum
demez iyi bir rehber her şeyi bilir kötü
bir rehber uydurur Hatta kötü bir rehber
gerçeğe yakın Yalan söyleyen kişidir
Allah'tan öyle bir yeteneğim vardı benim
gerçekten hala uydurarak hayatıma devam
ediyorum ama oturda gerçekten çok şey
uydurdum Hatta ondan böyle birkaç ay
sonra küçük bir İngiliz gurubuyla Çıktım
ben artık tecrübeleri verdim onlar benim
bu uydurma yeteneğimi keşfettiler Bizler
gibi rol boşver uydurursa ben uydurarak
bir tur yaptım Bu arada biz de çok dalga
geçiyorlar falan bize ikide 18 atıyorlar
milli takım olarak Neyse ben de onlara
bu arkeolojiden böyle biraz laf sokmaya
çalışıyorum biliyorsunuz herşeyin
orjinali bitiş müziği da dır Bunlar
almışlar çalmışlar bitiş müziği ama
götürmüşler Ben böyle şöyle şeyler
uydurmaya başladım arkadaşlar dedim Sağ
tarafta gördü bu İstanbul Boğazı dır 22
kilometre uzunluğundadır 100 metre
derinliğindedir ortalama ama orjinal
değildir orijinal British museum'da dır
diyormuş köprü gösteriyordum orjinali
British müziğinden Other diyordum Ondan
sonra mesaj Van Gölü için bile dedim bu
orijinali British müziğinden aramızda ve
uydurma bütün oldu Neyse ilk sonra
döneyim çok uzatmayacağım zaman büyük
ihtimalle yeterli gelmeyecektir
adamların başına gelenler için Konya
dayız Biz Mola yerini kaybettik yine bu
fakat adamların tuvalete girmesi lazım
dedim Yılmaz abi
bizim bir yerde mola vermemiz lazım Çok
kolay bir oluşum dedi tak bir yerde
durdu kamyoncu olduğu için Mola
yerlerinde çok iyi biliyor mu Sadece
kamyoncuların durduğu yeri biliyordu bir
girdik bizim olay yerine her taraf
kamyoncu tır falan
bizim bir çift çok yaşlı bir çift adam
koşarak geldi yanıma bir ol dedim ne
dedi buraya yerleşmeye karar verdik dedi
Karım çok mutlu dedi Burada ev bakacağız
dedi Ne oldu dedim 50 yıldır olmayan
birşey oldu dedi Ne oldu dedim Herkes
karımın bacaklarına bakıyor dedi
tesisin sahibi geldi Sen de grubu topla
buradan bir an önce gidin dedi biz
oradan Kapadokya gittik
Kapadokya o kadar büyük bir coğrafi ki
Niğde Nevşehir Kayseri üçgeninde
bilirsiniz Biz bile bulduk kapadokya'yı
bulduk birkaç böyle visit yaptık sonra
öğle yemeğindeyiz ben hiç unutmuyorum
Yılmaz abiye gittim de biraz abi dedim
gel bu adamları Biz çok acı çektirdik ya
adamların başına gelen gelmeyen kalmadı
Gel dedim bunları bir Show yapalım nokta
atış yapalım Bu sefer dedim bulalım ya
Çünkü adamlar bizim bir yeri bulacağımız
da dair inançlarını kaybettiler geldim
burayı bulalım dedi Bir oğlum sen merak
etme dedi yanındaki her türlü Hemşehrim
dedi bana anlattı Dedi Bu sefer dedi ben
size öyle götüreceğim ki tak diye
bulacağız dedi de ise gittik Yıldız abi
durdu Burası dedi ama in cin top oynuyor
O zaman kimse yok burada dedim Burası
dedi Sen merak etme bir vadi arıyoruz
vardı fotoğraf çekecekler
501 Vadi indirdik dedi 100 metre yürü
oradaymış dedi Vadi başladı biz yürüme
100 metre 200 metre 300 mi kilometre
olduğu bir buçuk kilometre oldu ben dua
ediyorum Allah'ım hali hiç bir yeri
bulamadık ama sonuçta 38 kişi tamamlamak
istiyorum turu Ben bir ölebilir çok
yaşlılar Kapadokya çok sıcak bir yer
kapalı çok ilginç bir yer yazları sıcak
Kışları soğuk
ve Yürüdük yürüdük işte şöyle
anlatıyoruz sana daha doğrusu Uy
duruyoruz Bu bir yerden bir döndük bütün
otobüsler orada Biz hariç bütün otobüs
bütün turistler otobüsle gelmişler bir
tek biz yürüyoruz ben hemen dedim ki
işte dedim bu cennet Vatan Bu Dünya
Mirası topraklara bu otobüsleri sokmayan
bu egzoz kazandı sokmayan buraya
yürüyerek gelen bir tek Sizsiniz
sizin atalarınız da hıristiyanlığı
burada yürüyerek yayılmıştı lütfen
kendiniz alkışlayın dedim alkış kıyamet
koptu da gözleri doldu
uzatmayayım Kapadokya bölümü çok ben
tedex yetmez buna
İstanbul'a geldik İstanbul'u Yılmaz
abinin de katkısı büyüktü Allah için
Çünkü İstanbul'u buluyordu yani çünkü
çok Mersin'den finikeden falan portakal
çektiği için İstanbul elinde koymuş gibi
bulduk
şimdi Yılmaz abi istanbul'da İstanbul'da
böyle çok relux bir günümüz var
oh oh Çamlıca Tepesi'ne çıkacağız
Tarabya'da balık yiyeceğiz Ondan sonra
Kariye Müzesi var Kariye Müzesi var ya
facia bir rehberin başına gelebilecek en
kötü şey Hıristiyanlık tarihi yam üst
Cami olsa hiç sorun değil ben hani
sonuçta kasaba çocuğu teravihe bile
gitmişliğim iz var idare ediyoruz
camilerde Show yapıyorum ama kiliseden
korkuyorum Hazreti İsa Sembol sen can
hiç bilmiyorum İşin kötüsü adamlar
biliyor yani Hristiyanların
hıristiyanlığı anlatacağım Bir de ben
anlatacağım falan Neyse Çamlıca'da
Elimde bir kitap Sürekli okuyorum Karya
okuyorum Çamlıca'da okuyorum balık
yerken okuyorum Neyse balığı yedik ben
sürekli kucağımda karye caminin Kariye
Müzesi'nin kitabı devamlı okuyorum
arabayla Beşiktaş'tan şeye gidiyoruz
Tarlabaşı'nda Unkapanı'nda döneceğiz
Fatih Kariye Müzesi'ni gezeceğiz arada
bu mikrobu işte burası Beşiktaş burası
Emirgan falan kısa cümle artık
anlatacaklarım da bitti Vallahi bir ara
şey dedim Burası Göz Göze Geldiğimiz Yer
Burası Diz Dize Türkçe falan konuşmaya
başladım ama stresliyim Çünkü Kariye
gidiyoruz
tarlabaşından aşağı indik
arkadan birisi sordu bir oldu Şu sol
taraftaki ne ne Süleymaniye biliyorum
İstanbul böyle bildiğim zamanda çok
karizmatik konuşuyorum dedim Süleymaniye
Camii Mimar Sinan'ın harikasıdır altı
minaresiyle İslam dünyasının güzel
camidir dedim önce bir sessizlik oldu
Sonra bir uğultu Ben de bunu biliyorum
artık aramızda bir değil oluştu dedim
Birol Acaba sen yine ne pot kırdın Bir
baktım süleymaniye'nin 4 cam dört
minaresi var Ben altı dedim
Sultanahmet'te karıştırmışım
sultanahmetin de bir özelliği var Altı
Minare var ya minareller nereden
bakarsanız Düzü küfür bu mühürlü App
olmaz Hemen mikrofon aldım dedim ki bu
dedim Mimar Sinan'ın şaheseridir
6 bina re si vardır ama nereden
bakarsanız bakın dört gözükür dedim
Sonra ben vazgeçtim Tabii bir turizm
şirketinde çalışmaya başladım zaten Yeni
evlenmiştim uzakları da gitmek
istemiyorum çok turizm şirketinde Çok
sıkıldım yolum yazıyla kesişti benim
yazmaya başladım sıkıldığım için yazdım
o iş o kadar büyüdü ki işte biliyorsunuz
diziler filmler tiyatro oyunları
kitaplar falan sonra yıllar sonra biraz
para kazanınca dedim ki ben ya şu
insanları bir arayayım gelsinler Uçak
biletlerini alsınlar ben bir gezdireyim
bunları bu vicdanım rahatlasın mail
attım hepsi ölmüş
ve bütün bunları niye anlatıyorum
Hani diyorlar ya asla vazgeçme Asla Pes
Etme İnsan isterse her şeyi yapar bu
doğru değil arkadaşlar hayat istesek de
başaramayacağı mız şeylerle doludur
Bu mutluluğun formülü yok ama mutsuzluk
elimizde Schopenhauer diyor ki bu
mutluluk mutsuzluğun yokluğudur bir
video ki yani mutlu olmaya çalışmayın
mutsuzluğunu zla baş edin Mutsuzluk
nedir mutsuzluk Ait Olduğun yeri
bulamamak demektir yanlış eşleşme
demektir işle eşle meslekle yanlış
eşleşme dir
benim vazgeçtiklerim benim pes
ettiklerimin Hepsi benim Yanlış
eşleşmelerinde Benim yolum Benim yolum
Benim yolum yazmakla kesildikten sonra
hiç kimse gelip bana Asla Pes Etme asla
vazgeçme demedi tek söyledikleri sen
dinlen biraz tatile çık falan oldu şimdi
zamanımızda olduğu için biraz eksik
olacak ama ben bu kürsiye uygun son bir
cümlemi söyleyeyim
İnsan isterse her şeyi Başarır Eğer ait
olduğu yeri bulursa ve çok çalışırsa
teşekkür ederim